welcome to this evening's meeting with
planning and development management
committee
and just by way of introduction my name
is adam williams i serve as the chair of
the committee
also present on this call of the
committee vice chair councillor ben
hartley
office has been the council's planning
service legal and democratic services
local highway authority as well as
elected councillors who make all the
voting members of the committee
and before we turn to the business of
the meeting i should advise everyone's
information that this meeting has been
live streamed and recorded
so please mute your microphones to
minimize background noise
if you wish to speak on an item please
use the chat facility
to notify myself and then wait until
you're invited to speak
um i'm moving through the agenda i'm
just on attendances
i have received apologies from council
accordingly
um and it's too late for a substitute
member to be arranged
and also apologize from councillor carey
who i understand
is being substituted by councillor
holden thank you very soon
councillor um
just for noting um item two on the
agenda is the council of bunting is now
replaced councillor rigby is the
opposition spokesperson and the
committee
uh welcome back councillor and moving
forward item number three are there any
members looking to declare an interest
for any of the applications
okay um item number four minutes have
been circulated
um anyone happy to propose that they're
an accurate blackboard
after second chair if somebody just
proposed to override the counselor
and counsel hartley let's try it's okay
take them as approved
um item number five i haven't been
notified of any
questions haven't been submitted by
members of the public
there haven't been any circulated uh
item number six
additional information report that was
circulated to members earlier
in the day via email and then item
number seven
are the applications for consideration
this evening
and the first application that we're
going to look at is 13 stamford place
which is on page one of the committee
report
and before we turn to the discussion
that's going to be introduced by mr
pearce
can i ask can everybody uh see the
screen
yeah okay this application relates to a
three-story three-bedroom property uh
and terrace property located on stanford
place
you see here on the corner of montague
road
close to sailtown center site features
front and side gardens
and a shared driveway to the rear
through through here
with adjacent properties numbers 9 and
11 32 here
the application that's the existing uh
built building by the way
front side and rear reservations and
the existing site plan you can see that
the house has a fairly generous side
garden here
and those are the proposed drawings so
the application speaks planning
permission direction of a
single story side extension the one you
see
down here as viewed from the front and
here is viewed from the side you'll note
that it has
a part of it is as a lean-to roof and
part of it a flat roof
to help accommodate these two juliet
balcony windows
that you see on third elevation here
there are replacement windows proposed
throughout the property
and an integral garage to the rear of
the property
is to be converted to
a living
there's a new single driveway and drop
kerb uh
pose to the front of the property just
go back to site plan
that's in in here um
but the property would remain used as a
single dwelling
several objections have been received
from neighbouring properties
and counselors on design and amenity
ground
alongside parking concerns and the
possibility that the property might be
used as apartments
the site has had a previous planning
application for a change of use to three
apartments refused
grounds of lack of parking and
inadequate size of the total
accommodation
proposed development is considered to
provide an acceptable design and
appearance
whilst providing adequate on-site car
parking for dwelling
on not harming the immunity of
surrounding neighbours
while the loss of a single front tree is
regrettable
it's not considered reasonable to
withhold planning permission for this
reason
consider that the proposal complies with
the relevant policy
guidance for households or extensions
and on balance will be an acceptable
scheme so he's recommended
i just finished off the presentation uh
i think you saw the uh
that's the ground floor plan see the
additional width there to to the right
and the parking space um some
photographs of property
this is the tree at the front that's to
be removed there are two
other existing mature trees within the
garden
along as you can see on this photograph
here with some
other fairly dense planting
and there's a few more photographs
showing the side elevation where the
judek bank
balconies go and this is the integral
garage which will be
converted to accommodation
okay so i'll take the uh
the drawings down now thank you chairman
thank you mr pearson um i understand
there's two speakers looking to speak
against
the um recommendation um
councillor butterton and rachel gibbons
uh have you
determined between yourselves who who'd
like to speak first
if this is good but miss steven wants to
go first chair that would be
okay um miss gibbons i can see you in
the
column you've got three minutes to speak
to committee and if you do um
go over time i'll just politely ask that
you try to wrap up your remarks
lovely thank you i'll start now i'm
speaking on behalf of the residents uh
regarding this application on 13
stanford place
and the main areas for our objections
remain as follows
parking both off-site where the space on
road is already severely limited
and on-site where there's a shared
access driveway
we have not objected to the front
driveway proposal but request
clarity on whether it's one space or two
and we have not objected to the removal
of a mature tree
even though it does not improve the
amenity of the area
site plan specifically the juliet
balconies which
directly overlook montague road it's
stated that the trees will screen these
properties
but for at least half the year the trees
are knotted in leaf thus providing a
strong degree of being overlooked and in
fact the photo
you showed earlier if you look at it you
can see that the windows are not in
front of the trees
the proposal for three beds three
lounges
has a way of flying under the radar to
bed sits or the potential for an hmo
as opposed to a true single dwelling and
repeated concerns over over occupancy
potential for the building
the potential for applying to make what
is a single story approval
into a multi-store approval at a future
date
the building line it's the residents
understanding that there would need to
be a substantive reason to move the
building line one which would improve
the amenity of the area as a whole
not just the building making the
application we can see no justification
for this
and the potential for the setting of a
precedent which would allow any house
along that side of montague road
to then move their building line forward
getting rid of their driveways and
causing potential for even greater
on-road parking issues
drainage and fire reports we've received
no notification
that these are part of the plan
disturbance during the rebuild we
request
conditions for reasonable working hours
as with respect there are young children
in both the adjoining properties in the
terrace
unimpeded access to the shared driveway
and the potential for avoidance of
damage to both the driveway and the
neighbour's car
cars through lack of due care and
attention on behalf of the trades people
visual appearance items out of character
with the adjoining and surrounding
properties
including grey windows juliet balconies
and now the intention to change the
rendering
which is common to all three properties
the property boundary
we have provided a copy copy of the
property deeds which show
very clearly the rear driveway access
has limitations
we have requested a condition be placed
upon the during parking during the
renovation
in order to avoid any damage to the rear
driveway now that there is
increased provision up front we asked
this consideration as a gesture of
goodwill
as the report states that the trees on
the property are to be protected during
building works
and with the greatest of respect we
would ask that they afford us the
residents this degree of protection as
well
without this consideration the granting
of the application would effectively
be months of misery we have had no
consideration from the applicant nor any
communication at all
and i thank you for your time
you miss skipping um counselor
brotherton you've got five minutes to
speak and similarly if you
go over time i'll just politely request
that you have the remarks thank you
thank you chair i don't think i'll need
the five minutes that mrs gibbons has
covered most of the points i was going
to make
first of all can't just say chair that
uh just to emphasize
the side extension will pro uh protrude
beyond the building line on montague
road
and uh whilst the officers don't
place a great deal of uh importance on
that
it it this is a corner plot and it won't
set an unfortunate precedent i think i
don't think it's something
we should be encouraging people to build
beyond the building line the building
line is there for a purpose
the reason that this property has a
large garden relatively large garden
is because it's set back back behind the
existing building line
the boundaries as the residents said
will overlook some of the properties on
montague road
i did notice as well that some of the
pictures shown uh
in the presentation in winter the trees
don't provide any screening at all
so those those balconies will look
directly into some of the houses
opposite uh
externally this application is very
similar to the one that
uh was mentioned which was for three
flats and which was turned down by the
planning committee
uh obviously the the application
was divided into three properties which
was turned down paragraph 35 of your
report
emphasizes the concerns of residents
about
the bottled water out turn of the
present uh application
i appreciate that any intention to
subdivide the property would require
permission however the present proposal
does seem to offer the
prospect of further internal changes for
example conversion of lounges to main
bedrooms
installation of extra extra bathrooms
the office's report does mention this so
it's
touches on this at one point uh
sorry we had anything in use so they
wouldn't actually need
permission for that so people are
concerned really that uh
that an informative note should be added
to the effect that the permission is for
a single dwelling
and any further change in use and status
would require
planning permission it's also suggested
chair that any permission
should be limited to use class c3 and
should not include any use for
short-term let's
for example airbnb typelets and similar
services
as the resident also said this is part
of a block of three tera
three in effect terrorist town houses
any work on this house
would be a great disturbance to the
immediate neighbors
so if you are minded to grant permission
then we will also ask that conditions
should be applied to limit the hours of
work
to those considered reasonable and to
minimize their nuisance and disturbance
to the immediate neighbors thank you
chair
thank you uh council brothers and um
speaker
in favor of the application i believe is
coverline payne
hello yes chair hi um so similarly to um
the first video you've got three minutes
pain and um as i said previously if you
go over time we'll just like this that
you you wrap up your room thank you
thank you chair members i'm caroline
payne for memory planning and i've asked
been asked to speak in support of the
application
planning permission was refused in
october 2020 for the conversion of this
property to three apartments
the applicant has listened to the advice
from your planning officers
and now proposes to refurbish the house
as a family home
together with a modest single-story
extension
the property has had very little
investment over the past 50 years
at present there is a garage and sitting
room at ground floor level
a kitchen and lounge at first floor
level and three bedrooms on the second
floor
the alterations and single-story
extension will create a kitchen dining
family space at ground floor
two further reception rooms at first
floor and the existing bedroom
arrangements
on the second floor it will be upgraded
as a contemporary family home in a
sustainable location
two car parking spaces are provided and
your highways officer has raised no
objection
in response to the concerns raised by
neighbours the increase in floor space
is very modest about 18 square meters a
small single story extension
the loss of the garage is offset by
additional parking space
there will be no loss of parking and all
standards are met
all residential amenity standards are
met the applicant does intend to
implement this planning permission
any change if used to apartments or hmo
would require a further planning
application
and would be subject to scrutiny of your
planning officers and this committee in
any event
the tree to be removed isn't protected i
think that's picked up in the report and
that could be removed in any event
in terms of the reference to the
building line and this is an end plot so
it wouldn't set a precedent for other
properties on montague road
but i do note from looking at the plan
at the at the back of the report
that 8a at the opposite end of montague
road also
projects belong the the theoretical
building line
in summary i support the conclusion of
your planning officers
and hope that you're able to support the
recommendation thank you chair
thank you mr peng and that's the
speakers to this item are there any
members looking to open the discussion
no no one's indicating and
i suppose i think the council brotherton
and um
mrs gibbons raised a number of points um
during their representations and i was
just wondering whether or not
um it will be possible for
one of the planning officers perhaps to
pick up on some of those items
um i think in particular and in council
bulletin's
written representation he referred to
impact during construction and upon
neighbouring residents and also about
whether or not
it would be possible to put on
conditions and i was just wondering if
we could reflect on that perhaps
yeah thank you chairman i mean just in
relation to to the last point i mean
disturbance to
to neighbors um obviously that's the we
often put a construction management plan
on
larger planning applications you know
where you've got extensive building
works going on that might
last some time i mean on a small
house extension which this is we
wouldn't really consider that to be
reasonable
i mean the committee could put it on if
they wished but
um from an officer perspective we don't
think it's really reasonable
for the size of the extension um
i mean you know and other points were
raised in terms of sort of damage to
property damage to driveways
again unfortunately those are not
planning issues that we could reasonably
cover you know it is down to the
neighbours and the applicants
behave in a reasonable way and make sure
that they don't cause any damage to
to the neighboring properties
i think those were with a kind of key
issues was talking about
unimpeded access i mean again it's not
really something that the committee
should be getting involved
on a house extension application um we
obviously note as we did in the report
the
concerns of the neighbours about the
possibility that the property could be
at some point in the future uh split
into flats but
as has been said already uh that that
would need planning permission you know
so there's another opportunity there
for the committee to to consider whether
or not that's appropriate
but at the moment you know we need to
consider the application as it's
as it stands and it is a fairly modest
single story side extension so i hope
that covers the main issues but happy to
to come back and cover more of this
channel that's great thank you mr
pearson i think
bringing some of the members into the
discussion now we're councillor hartley
thank you chair it was just there was
one other point which um
which might might be helpful to have
officers advice on uh which was
uh miss gibbons mentioned the the shared
drive at the back of the property
uh and you know needing access um
through that shared drive
um i'm sure that situation's probably
come up before an application so
yeah i wonder whether we can consider a
condition that that the access through
that shared drive be kept clear
um during the duration of the works um
i'll just
make a few other comments over may and
then um and then i appreciate an officer
might want to give some input
into that i mean i think the last thing
mr pearson said is probably
um the most relevant in a way that it is
a modest single story
uh extension um i do
i mean i do have concerns but i don't
think there are reasons to
refuse this application on planning
grounds so the
the two offer of parking spaces i think
is probably adequate for
for a three bed house but uh you know
looking at the plans
they are unusual i suppose i could say
that in that they have three lounges so
that could easily become a four or five
bedroom house with more cars and
a more impact on the area so i do have a
concern about that and also a concern
about
um you know the property being
subdivided i know we've we've had this
before and i know that would require
a separate application but but looking
at the plans i think i
i take cancer brotherton's point that it
that it could easily be converted to
to separate uh livings places you know
by putting a few doors in
uh basically um but i think
uh you know it is a spacious plot it's a
modest single story extension
i think certainly at the moment the the
side
uh elevation surrounded by a lot of
mature planting and quite a high
fence so i actually think they there
won't be
an impact on the street since i think
you'll you'll hardly be able to
to see it um and and the way the street
scene is at the moment that
that sort of corner is very um you know
mature and built up so you don't really
get a
any sort of appreciation for the
building line on montague road anyway
i know that bender treatment could could
change but
uh i think it's likely that if that's a
garden area it is
still going to have a a high fence and a
lot of the planting there so
i think on that basis chair i can't see
a planning reason
for us to refuse the application so
i'd be happy to to move that we agree
with the officer recommendation
um but might be useful to clarify the um
keeping the access to the shared drive
free if possible thank you
mr pearson i don't know do you want to
come in now or yeah
you're on mute present okay yes um
yeah i mean i i i take that the point
that the council hardly
raises there i mean again it's really a
matter that you would expect neighbors
to
to sort out between themselves um not
really something for for the planning
authority to
uh to seek control of um
and i certainly don't think we should be
attaching a condition that says keep the
driveway clear
i mean the one thing you could we could
committee could do
um and bearing in mind uh members might
have noticed that they
the highway authority had wanted a
construction method state
i think it was like uh i think that
their concern was
was that it's a fairly tight site on a
relatively busy junction um and so what
we could do is put a construction
management plan on if committee
so wanted um you know and that could
include
uh asking um asking for
the details relating to the parking of
site operatives
um storage of materials but
as i say i mean that's not something we
would normally recommend on a house
extension we would hope that
neighbours would would be neighborly but
i would sort out those
um issues themselves you know that is
something that we
we obviously didn't put the condition on
that the highway authority recommended
so um it's not one we'd recommend but i
guess the option is there
that that's helpful to know thank you i
think it become clear i think in the
course of the discussion about the
members
that support that and counselor bunting
thank you gentlemen and if i may just
very briefly just
preface my comments uh by as you said in
point two of the agenda so the
council brian rugby has been covering me
for the past few months because of the
changing times of the committee i was
like to put on record if i may
my thanks to him for doing that and uh
uh
so it's nice to be back but uh thank you
to brian rigby
for covering me during my absence in
terms of the application chairman uh i
agree pretty much with what your vice
chairman's had to say
uh it is a relatively modest first four
extensional bit with some uh juliet
balconies above
uh the first full aspect of the
extension is very well screened with the
sort of substantial concrete fence
that's in place
you're barely going to see it from the
street scene so in terms of the streets
nothing is mo
it's not going to have any particular
impact on that
at all um yes i appreciate that
some of the awesome concerns raised
about um future
plans and future subdivisions and what
have you but as has already been
uh pointed out that would be subject to
future planning control so not really
what we're dealing with tonight we have
to do with what's in front of us and not
start speculating
about what may or may not come down the
track in the future
if such applications arise well we'll
deal with those
at the time and com people will have the
right to express their opinions on them
as a when they're as a when they happen
in the car parking is has been pointed
out
uh once but the garage is being removed
but there is a
second space uh outside and i think
as a council heart is already states i
think two uh car parking spaces
is reasonable for for the uh
for for this property in terms of the
building line as there's been much made
of the building line yes it does jump
forward
uh slightly but then so does that has
been pointed out uh
by the speaker in favor 88 the other end
of the road does it pretty much the same
trick
so you if you look at the plan on uh
page 14
uh you've only really got those four
properties in between
uh that are affected by that and then
people say oh yes so the building line
the pr
in terms of precedence being set but as
you know as well as i do chairman there
are no precedence in planning
every application is dealt with on
inside merits so again uh i'm not going
to get overly concerned by that
uh i agree with council hartley that i
can't see any particular reason to
refuse it and
on that basis if i'm taking council
hartley as proposing
uh that we that we accept offers to
recommendation
i'm more than happy to uh to second that
thank you chairman
thank you councillor councillor proctor
uh thank you
chad um yeah i did have some initial
concerns when i
looked at this application um i think
most of them
have been addressed it is a fairly
modest increase in floor space so
there's nothing
uh specific there and much has been made
of the
parking issue basically
we're losing the the garage space well
that's being
um supplemented by the the extra
space that's been being created so i
don't think
you know parking is a particular issue
the
the major thing that does just concern
me is the overlooking aspect
particularly on montgomery road
particularly around about number 16
i think it is going to have have an
impact okay there's going to be some
screening
but that's not going to be there
throughout the year
i think it is particularly the position
that that aspect of the the application
i mean the officers have said
it's it's not going to have an
unreasonable effect on
the immunity so they've made that
assessment but i'm i'm
not so sure about that i think part of
the year there's going to be a certain
high degree of overlooking on certain
properties so is that enough to
to refuse the application um
i'm torn on him but probably not but i'm
prepared to listen to what other people
have to say
uh on that particular issue thank you
chair
thank you councillor procter and the
transmission for me did freeze a bit
during part of your
um comments that i had if other members
are concerned they've not heard
but you have to say it was only on the
part about um the overlooking
aspect concerns you have but if members
feel that you've not been heard then
please put in the chat or
however you wish to communicate
counselor minis thank you chair
um yeah i was looking at this i'm
thinking about the obviously the
building line was one thing made of it i
mean it is a single story it is
not going to be seen from um you know
cause issues with
line of sights down the road um because
if you've got you've got all
the the um it's not going to destroy
the street scene because you've got all
the screening around it anyway
um i don't see if it was a two-story
i would have a possible issue with it
but with a single story i think it's
quite
um you know within within i think a lot
of with
within what's what seems reasonable so
um i'll be
i'll be certainly in favor of it thank
you
thank you councillor um councillor
morgan
thank you chair i'm really gonna keep
this really brief because everyone else
has said exactly what i was i've been
thinking
um i mean when i looked down all the
issues parking i didn't really see the
issue
um as councillor bunting's already
raised um
in terms of the precedent on the
building line
it's already been interrupted on
montague road
um the one thing i actually do agree
with council procter i did
the one thing i'd probably say is i
don't like about this is juliet
balconies
but i really don't think that's enough
to oppose this
um so i'll be supporting it tonight
thank you
thank you councillor and no other member
having
indicated in the chat i'll give people a
moment or two they
do have a billion desire to speak
councillor hartley um mr pearson
mentioned about the
possibility of a construction management
plan is that something you feel
strongly about or having listened to
what you said
just wondering what you thought so no i
i don't think so i i
yeah i'd take the point that that's
that's usually for for much
much more major development so it it
seems disproportionate to
have a condition for that on a
application of this um
you know this size this small size thank
you
okay um thank you um
the application has been proposed by
councillor hartley seconded by
councillor bunting before we move to the
vote i did just myself want to
reflect on the fact that i think it's
been really welcome that um
members of public have brought their
concerns to committee they've engaged
with the process
um they've come up with some
constructive ideas and we've been able
to
discuss them i understand the concerns
around um
hmos and about um potentially the
uh extension becoming a much bigger
dwelling than what's been proposed but
what i'd say is you know that that that
would be for a future application to
determine
and those concerns could be raised
at that point and i hope that that
provides some reassurance
and i'll now move to the vote and i'll
just cycle through members as you pay on
my screen and cancel the proctor um
agree with officer recommendation to
grant thank you council the menace
um i'll agree with officer
recommendation to grant thank you
thank you councillor harley support the
officer's recommendation to grant
you councillor hartley thank you uh yeah
i agree officer's recommendation to
grant thank you
thank you councillor bunting yeah i
agree with the officer recommendation
thank you council jerome i also
support officer recommendation to grant
you thank you
councillor thomas i support churchill
thank you councillor stenning
oh i don't think that came through i
think it might be on mute counsellor
how's it standing can you mute and um
we'll move to councilman morgan i'm
councillor morgan
let's talk a spot of recommendations to
thank you councilman stanley has you
missed part of the debate
and the advice from democratic services
is that you
uh won't be able to cast a vote on this
application yeah
council of stannity have you
[Music]
yeah i've just said i've just had a
request to a mute from
uh the admin yeah i think he was aiming
for a councillor stand it
gives him a button to press okay
perhaps if we can give that another
attempt
and then i'll just confirm in that time
i i'm casting
my vote um in in line with officer
recommendation to graham
um i'll give councillors on it one more
opportunity just a thought chairman
if uh council standard can't get his uh
microphone to a mute for some reason
could he not vote via the chat
i know it's not usual but you could then
read out what he says
counselors done it i don't know if you
could put in the um
chat how are you voting on this
application
oh i don't know if we could receive some
advice from democratic services about
the best course of action here i mean
chair and i appreciate this is a zoom
caller not a team's call but i do know
in teams
the session controller can mute and
unmute people i don't know if that's
possible for
whoever the session can
consistent two governance offices on the
call
okay right you can see that advice
council talked about the i didn't come
to you i'm sorry right at the bottom of
the screen there
thank you chairman i support the
officer's recommendation to ground
right i mean the application on the
votes that have been cast is approved
um unanimously out of
the votes that we've received okay um
move to the next application which is 20
kendall road on page 29 of the committee
report
and it's going to be introduced by ms
coley
thank you chairman uh just bear with me
while i will i share my screen
can everybody say that
yes rebecca thank you um this
application relates to
um a property at number 20 kendall road
in stratford
uh part of uh well an end terrace on a
row of
terraces with a a gap which forms part
of the application site you can see
there and then another row of terraces
beyond uh and this is the the filling of
that gap which is of
um there's a main consideration in this
application
you can see on that plan there um that
the
the site comes around here so it's
number 20 so it's an extension to that
property as opposed to that property but
it would link into both
um again i'm just showing some
photographs first of all so that's so
that's understood it's effectively
filling this gap
here you see the gap there as well
um these are the these are the floor
plans
um the existing elevations
that being the application property that
being the neighboring property and that
being the gap
and the floor proposed floor plans
and then the elevation here
um so the application is recommended for
for refusal it has had two letters of
support and has been uh
uh called in by council walsh which is
why it's it's at the
in front of the committee this evening
um
officers uh primary concern is around
design and appearance and street scene
uh and in that um two
two main issues there's um the
the filling of the gap between the two
terraces and the impact that would have
on the rhythm of the street scenes
you've got a terrace and a gap than a
terrace
and that gap's quite important in in
when you look down the street and
understanding how the street works and
the character and filling that would
have
would effectively lead to one long
terrace and then there's the appearance
of the extension
itself on the frontal elevation uh in
terms of
the fact that the window because the
gap's too narrow effectively to
replicate
terrace either side um and and doesn't
sit proportionally with either it's very
difficult to
er indeed impossible to design an
extension which which fits with either
um property uh you can match one each
line and not the other you can match the
detailing on one and not the other
the bricks are completely different um
and in particular in terms of the bricks
and i'll
i'll show you some precedent images is
this the the intention is to
build the extension flush across the
frontage
and tooth the bricks in either side you
will
you you will struggle to match either
one of the bricks but you certainly will
never match both because
they're completely different um and that
results
in uh this is this is a completely
different property i don't even know if
this is in the borough
but it results in that kind of effect um
where you've got difference and then
you've got the toothing and then
close-up
you can see what happens when you try
and when you try and do that
i mean these bricks are weathered on the
left-hand side here so obviously it
wouldn't
wouldn't quite look like that but but
again this is two toothing in
old and new brick um it very rarely
works successfully
um so as a result of that um
officers have recommended this for
refusal
uh on the grounds that we think it would
have a detrimental impact on on the
on the street scene uh and and the
character of the area and
it would appear in congress um we had
didn't invite any amended plans because
we couldn't see
possibly what could be done to actually
um
deal with the the fundamental issues of
trying to fill in the gap and actually
if the
um applicant wants to extend it would be
um
then they need to think about whether
that should be at the rear or something
like or something like that
thank you chairman thank you ms coley
i believe there's two speakers in favour
um of granting permission contrary to
officer recommendation ms saunders and
councilman walsh have you
determined you'd like to speak first
chair i was i'd suggested to miss
sanders that she would speak first i
don't know
if she's with us hi yeah i'm here
hi thank you thank you hi mrs um you've
got
three minutes to speak if you do um go
over time a bit i'll just politely
request
your contribution thank you all right um
well first of all i want to thank
everybody
time to review this application my
partner and i would like to build a side
extension of an existing garage
that is connected to the house next door
there are five people living at number
20.
me adam my partner and our three
children
serbia who's a sullen as we're
five-year-old twins
we all share one bathroom i work from
home in the bedroom
as it's the quietest place except is in
the smallest room and has a high cabin
bed with a wardrobe and desk underneath
he used to be in the second largest
bedroom but i had to move because
it wasn't big enough to accommodate two
beds for his brothers
so frequently tells me he's scared of
heights and wants a low bed again
the boys are growing and will soon
outgrow the house
we want to remodel the interior to
maximize space and building regulations
have approved the plans for this
building a side extension would improve
our quality of life
there is concern from planning because
the house next door number 22 was built
approximately 25 years earlier
and linking two architectural styles
with a different shade of red brick is
not standard practice
and distant guidance must be followed
but i
disagree the front of our houses are in
line the garage already links the two
houses together
and an extension would improve the
street by filling in a random gap in the
middle of it
we want the style to be in keeping with
the assistant house and for it to fit in
as much as possible
the house is tired and needs renovating
and improving this area we
hope to enhance the stream on kindle
road alone there are six architectural
styles of houses
terrace is sitting next to one another
in built in different areas
there's also multitude of different
facade colours
um from brown bricks to red bricks
to rendered to
so many different styles there's not
only that there's like different styles
of architectural styles it's
from the last hundred years the variety
of architectural styles have changed
and i'm not requesting to add an
additional style
just simply extending an original one
the neighbors are very supportive of
this project
and if there are any problems i have no
doubt they would tell me in the kindle
world whatsapp group
it's got a strong community feeling
we can't afford to buy a larger house in
this area because we'd have to pay an
extra two hundred thousand pounds
to get a four or five bed house have
looked into this as an option
the only alternative is to move into a
more affordable area
but that means a change of schools for
the children
and and it's not something that i want
to do
thank you for your time thank you
and ms saunders and councillor walsh
you've got five minutes to speak and
you go every time a little bit as you
know you'll be asked to
thank you chair and apologies for the
dark picture i tried to adjust it but um
i'm just a little bit in the dark but i
hope you can hear me uh good evening
chair planning committee and officers
thank you for allowing me to speak
to this application this evening i think
the need for the extension is quite
clear
this is a young family a young growing
family who wants to stay in the area
and stay in local schools they genuinely
don't want to move to make a decision
this evening we have to look at the
planning issue
around the application rather than the
reasons for it
that is the effect the extension would
have on the street scene
we all want to protect street scene on
kendall road
and everywhere else in the borough of
trafford
i was a member of the planning committee
when we approved the marlin way
application
in 2002. i think it's fair to say that
that has
been a success the newer kendall road
houses
were part of the marlin way application
they
are on the opposite side to number 20
and numbered
seven to 57 kendall road they have
three different building styles compared
to the older properties opposite
and benefit from a large green spray
space to the front
i think we need to think about that
wider street scene
when considering this application
to be blunt if this application
concerned a narrower street
with one style of housing on both along
both sides
of it i will be more aware of that
street scene but kendall road is much
wider
with a number of different styles on
both sides of the road
trafford planning officers rightly want
to protect street scene
but the space to be protected between
numbers 20
and 22 i believe is hardly noticed by
cars or pedestrians passing by
consultation letters have been sent to
neighbours with no adverse comments
rather letters of support have been
received from numbers
18 and number 22.
in summary i don't believe the marginal
change in the street scene
this application would make is so
significant
that it warrants the application being
refused
in short the benefits outweigh the
negatives
thank you again for allowing me to speak
thank you councillor walsh and
i can see some members of council thomas
i think you've indicated like to speak
thank you chair uh having visited the
the site um one thing that i didn't
notice from living in the terrace myself
is that if this went ahead and obviously
due care and attention would
need to be uh taken to try and marry up
as much as we can uh the brickwork but
it would enhance and make the terrace a
full terrace
similarly to bonus street and
on both sides uh the actual bonus street
to the rear of
the property has only two or three less
houses
in a full terrace run i can't see any
any reason why that we can't
allow this development and i do think it
will enhance
completely um the full terrace
uh so i i would be looking to go against
the office
recommendation on this
okay thank you councillor and councillor
winston
uh thank you chair yeah i also uh will
be pushing to vote against
the officer's recommendations when i
also when i visited the site and
i applaud the planning officer's desire
to preserve the street scene absolutely
but the the gap in the terrace i think
detracts from the
from the street scene um coupled with
the fact you've got
a very incongruous looking garage in the
gap
uh there's also as some
councilor walsh said there's a huge
mixture of architectural styles on this
on this street anyway so i don't think
filling that gap
actually detracting the streets streets
here i think it would add to it
um and after the old and new brick well
that's just the nature of the beast
isn't it
when you when you change buildings you
can never match
the original um the original materials
that i use and we've seen this in many
applications before this committee
and as long as done sympathetically
we're usually very happy to
um to allow that to happen so
uh if council thomas's uh
comments were to to move that we vote
against
the um officer's recommendation i would
second
that motion that we vote against the
opposite recommendation and we have to
grant this application
i'm not sure that he has proposed that
motion uh councilman stanley
yeah i'm happy to propose right
okay thank you chad
thank you um councillor bunting
thank you chairman um
i'm going to disagree with the two my
two colleagues have spoken previously
and
whilst i accept the reasons as to why
the applicant wants
to um to to do what they want to do in
terms of you know
creating more space uh i do feel that
the
impact on the street scene is going to
be significant people have mentioned the
fact that
uh there's a gap and there's a garage in
the gap at the moment and i think
councilman stanley was who mentioned
that the
the garage congress and indeed i would
agree with him absolutely on that point
if you were
if you were interested in uh preserving
the street scene and doing everything
you could to
it's a street scene you'd simply take
the garage away and that would be the
best solution for the street scene
uh i also accept that there's a mix of
stars in the area but this is that's not
what we're referring to here we're
talking about he's trying to glue
together two different styles
and that's the point that mrs cody was
making she was making her point that
you'll never
you you might not too much one side or
the other but you're never going to be
able to make them both because it's
simply not possible
unless the extension is going to somehow
morph itself subtly over the course of
its width
from one star to the other which if you
can manage that trick i'll
congratulate you you deeply so i think
it is going to look
very odd and uh yes i appreciate people
might say oh well
does it really matter if it looks odd if
it doesn't matter if it sticks out like
a sort of thumb
it it's respect you know it allows
people to do what they want to do
and we'll live with that but i i don't
think that's a reasonable uh course of
action especially when there are
alternatives
as mrs kelly has pointed out that they
could extend me to the rear or something
such as that
and then that would uh avoid the need as
i said
which is normally needed for garage it's
not used for anything well if a gallery
if you're just gonna come back and say
we're gonna take the garage away
everyone will be fine with that
but it's it's it's it's not the
infilling of it and also
if i made this before i finished i think
again it's kind of like stone you said
it but it's it's not a
massively lengthy terrace and there are
many terraces in areas that are longer
if this was one solid length of terrace
and there was no gap at all and it was
all the same style of terrace going all
the way along
then that would also be absolutely fine
but you can't revert you can't
change history and make it like that so
trying to just jam a bit in to create
the whole terrace
is gonna look like a it's gonna look
terrible um
so on those grounds jim although i'm
appreciate what the person is trying to
do
there are other ways of doing it i can't
go along this and i will uh propose
recommend that we
go with the officer recommendation thank
you chairman
thank you councillor councillor morgan
thank you chair um yeah i'm going to
agree with cancer bunting um
i really want to disagree with officer
recommendations but i think it's
actually
quite clear in terms of both in the mppf
and
the council policy in terms of why we
can't do this
um it's a real shame um but
and if this was a terrorist set of
terrorists where there was a lot of
inconsistencies and i do i do
except on the streets there is but
actually from 20 through to i think it's
six at the
end um i'm in line with the railway on
station road
there is actually a real consistency
which this would breach
um and yeah the garages
doesn't help and it is it's it's an odd
street and i
and it's a really unusual one but i
honestly think if we're going to follow
what where the council policy which is
in line with what we're supposed to be i
honestly can't see how we can support
this i will be voting in favor
in line with office recommendations to
refuse thank you
thank you council holder
counselor i think you are new still
sorry
double clicking sorry how's that yep
i found myself in a slightly difficult
position here some of you may remember
the end of last year i came to
this committee to support an objection
from a resident about the uh
change from a garage to a living space
right next to our house the change from
link detached to effectively
linked and said
that's the concern that i have here that
you're
putting living accommodation right up
against the first
floor wall and the ground floor
of number 22 i believe
now did i hear the fact that the
resident number 22 the next door
neighbor
whose house is going to be absorbed by
this change
has actually supported this
this application
because that's if i've seen you nodding
so i
said that that's probably the case
i think it's very altruistic i do hope
that they've thought about it
i can't see any major planning reason
to deny this application
so i'm still thinking very hard as to
whether or not
i will go with the recommendation of the
officers
or with the my colleagues who've
made a very good case for denying it so
if i can just have
two more minutes to think and then i'll
work thank you
thank you councillor and councilman
thank you chair i'm really torn it's
really difficult um i feel like
um like uh councillor bunting's saying
like the best thing was
it would be to get rid of the garage if
you wanted to make it all you know
look right and but obviously they've got
the garage already there you can't be
taking the thing down
and and if you could join them up so
that it
all matched and it looked right and the
stand that gap size was the same as like
say
a room online room on either side so it
kind of looked right
in size as well then then that would be
okay
but uh by the sounds of it that's not
the case and it's sort of like that bit
narrower
is that right um it's coley is it a bit
narrower
yes counselor yes thank you thank you so
i think that really although
i really i'm really really i felt so
sorry i feel so sorry for actually the
applicant because i can
completely understand what what she
needs to try and do for her family
um but i feel like you can't
really do it there's also the matter of
n terraces rn terraces
and you're basically turning the turning
that the two and terraces into mint
terraces effectively
i think that it's just there's too many
no's and there's
i i feel like i want to say yes but i
think i'm gonna have to go with
with office correct recommendation thank
you
you councillor councillor thomas you've
indicated that speak
thank you chair yeah just uh just to
point out that the garage is actually of
no
similar brick to either side and
attached to both ends
and if you i know that we can't um
direct how people decorate them from
other properties if you're looking at
the property
two houses to the left are two different
colors now i'm aware that
architecturally the brick and
the difference in the brick and the bay
windows upstairs
are different and do pose a
a degree of incongruousness
for one of a better word um to the to
the roofline
and the guttering but that's that's
quite easily overcomeable
i i just i can't see any reason as to
why there is a re why we can
support the decision to refuse
when if you go around the the back of
the same property
there is a terrorist line exactly the
same with differences
and across the road there are completely
different houses to
the whole road that there are new houses
um
so if barry has proposed it as i didn't
i'm happy to second barry's uh motion to
um grant planning
okay thank you councillor um i will just
give members who haven't spoken the
opportunity to indicate if they did want
to come into the
debate uh i i
wouldn't say i just did this property
this time myself this afternoon
i can't come in with any uh really
technical observations but one thing
that did strike me was that when i was
sort of stood in front of them
it does look as though one terrace is
actually higher
in height than the other terrorists and
i was just wondering
miss corey if you could clarify that
because the thing that struck me about
that was i just
didn't know how it would be possible to
sort of neatly carry out
this extension if that's the case it
seemed to me that you'd have this sort
of sloping effect on the roof so i was
just wondering if perhaps you could
clarify the issue with the height
yes i can thank you chairman um they are
at different heights the eaves are at
different heights and that is one of the
the um the issues that we pointed out
that you can only
match one set of leaves not both so you
wouldn't necessarily slope it but there
would be and i can show you all the
plans what
what exactly is uh proposed for that if
it would be helpful
but no they wouldn't line up
okay um counselor dr barkley okay
thank you chair before i just uh give my
views is it possible through you chair
to see
uh what mrs cody was um talking about in
terms of the eid it would be quite
useful to have a look at that please
thank you yeah
i'm happy with that yeah certainly just
bear with me while i
when i screen share again then um
hopefully i'll be able to zoom in um
so make sure it's the front
is that clear it's not particularly
clear for me
no um pixelated i think
okay just just bear with just bear with
me if if um
any i'll go and try and find the rather
than a
image on the slideshow i'll go and try
and find the plan
in the file that i can zoom in on if you
if you want to
to continue the discussion well i do
that if that's all right with you
chairman
that's fine counselor dr buckley did you
want to continue with your contribution
or would you like to
wait and we could hear counselor jerome
first yes if
i i'd like to see the picture of these
first please thank you chairman
okay thank you councillor jerome thanks
chad
um i really do synthesize with the uh
applicants on
on this because obviously extending your
your home in in the way that they want
to would really um afford them
you know better family life but um i
think as councilor bunting
uh put forward in his argument said they
can extend at the rear
um and when i did visit the street there
are
um a gap between between this house
obviously in the next door neighbor but
i think there's three down the street in
a pattern and
blocking this one up would kind of
interrupt that pattern
so i i do tend to agree with planning
officers here and i will be
um supporting officer recommendation on
this one
thanks chair thank you councillor and
mrs carly i don't know me a couple more
minutes so
if you could just give me a couple of a
couple of seconds while i just i'm just
having to to go in a different way to
fight to get the plan
i um i'm nearly there we'll have a
comfort break
um right i think i should be able to
share that with you now um
so
is is that clear to members i can see
that clearly now
do i need to zoom in a little bit
further i'm seeing nods
i can see it you can see it okay
excellent so
this is the application property and as
you can see that the eaves
follow through there but here
are the eaves of the neighboring
property there and so they've got this
is that this is their decorative
dental course um on that one but again
this this property is a bit
a bit different in terms of it's both
it's
it's window proportions um it's
unfortunate the whole of that property
isn't on that plan
um because it's it's clearer when you
stand in front of them
yeah i mean that that that's really
helpful from my perspective cancer
talked about they don't know if you'd
want to um proceed with everyone else
now yeah thank you very much tim and
thank you mrs code i think that is
really helpful and
and it's such a shame because i would
really love to support the application
and well support the the applicant with
the application because
clearly we all want residents to be able
to you know adapt their home so that
they become
really useful um properties but i'm
afraid there's just too much going
against this application
and we've seen with the eaves we've seen
with the street scene
um and the loss of the gap as well and
although i do think the white
the garage is in itself um not really
compatible with the streets and it is
already there
so we're not putting in something i mean
that's already there and we're not
replacing that with
um something that's um more appropriate
so unfortunately this is
truly with a heavy heart because i would
have loved to have said i support the
applicant and i'm going to have to
support officer's recommendation thank
you chair
thank you councillor dox bagley um no
members have indicated well no
additional members have indicated that i
would like to participate in the
discussion
and there has been a motion moved and
seconded that we
vote contrary to officer recommendation
and approve the application
will then move to the boat on that
motion
um first and i'll just month remembers
as you're appearing on my screen
and counselor property sorry chairman we
we will uh just need to clarify what the
reasons are for
for the overton i think i think i've
heard them i i can express them back to
the committee if that would be helpful
and you can
um i i think that members would wish to
to approve the application because don't
believe there would be harm to the
street scene
uh through filling the gap because of
the varied character of the surrounding
area does that does that sound fair
enough
yeah i'm getting i'm seeing nod so
that's that's fine that's fine chairman
in which case you can proceed to the
vote
thank you um councillor
that's a real tricky one i'm going to go
against the officer recommendation to
to refuse thank you counselor minis
i'm going with the officer's
recommendation i don't know how that
works for
vote thank you councillor hartley
thank you chair yeah i think it is a
really difficult one um i'm gonna vote
against emotion
uh i think that last picture that um
miss curly brought up was quite telling
that it's i think if the gap was more
even
it would be a less you know in congress
edition but as it is i think it does
have an impact on the street scene so
yeah against emotion sorry thank you
thank you councillor bunting
against chairman uh i remain supporting
the officer recommendation
thank you councillor yeah i'm also
against this motion
uh thanks jeff thank you uh councillor
thomas
i support the motion uh to go against
the officers
uh right thank you councillor stennett
i will support the officer's
recommendation
thank you councillor morgan i'm against
this motion chair
thank you councillor in stanley
uh thank you chair support the motion
thank you councillor holden but i
support
the officer's recommendation to refuse
please
thank you and counselor dr barkley
i don't support the um motion to
um overturn the officer recommendation
to refuse
thank you and i will be voting against
this
motion to overturn officer
recommendation
and i make that as three in support of
the motion and
nine uh against that motion um
it was also uh proposed and seconded
that
he votes in line with office of
recommendation to refuse permission will
now move to that vote and i'll just run
through members
again councillor proctor
before
can you try one more time again
thank you council um councillor minis
although with uh in favor of the
officer's recommendation to refuse thank
you
thank you councillor hartley thank you
chair yeah and
in favor of the officer recommendation
to refuse thank you
account for the bunting
so i put my teeth back in sorry about
that in favor of officer recommendation
to refuse
thank you council jerome i will say
support officer's recommendation to
refuse
thanks jim thank you councillor thomas
against the opposition recommendation
thank you councillor stennis
recommendation thank you councillor
morgan
um the recommendation to refuse chair
thank you councillor stanley uh thank
you
vote against the officer recommendation
uh to refuse
thank you and councillor dr barkley a
support
officer recommendation to refuse thank
you
and i will also be voting in line with
officer recommendation
to refuse permission
i think with that that motion is
carried and um application has been
refused
um we're mountain to 32 to 42 ingolby
court which is something page 15
at the committee report um
that application will be introduced by
ms milner
thank you chair i'll just share my
screen with you
so the application before members um
relates to 39 to 42 ingolby court in
stratford
and members may recall that this site
came before you in october
last year and the application then
as does it does now proposed external
alterations
to change the existing uh roof
to a mansard roof and changes to windows
and
porch way with four sorry five door
windows on the front elevation
and this application proposes
two um new apartments two one bed
apartments
as the previous application proposed one
apartment on one side and storage on the
other
physically the applications are
identical but internally they are
different
and the application proposes two parking
two additional demarcated
parking spaces as shown here on your
location plans and with facilities
for bins to the rear
these are just some images so this is
the existing block of flats
and then this is just the local area
to give you some context
the application is before members
because we have received
more than six objections from local
residents as
was with the previous applications
concerns are raised by residents on the
impact and from the character of the
area due to design but also
and considerable and concern about the
impacts on parking
demand within the area and
also the impact on the existing
residence and street scene character
and that impact on amenity officers do
appreciate that this is a change from
the previous approval
in terms of intensity of the use and
physically
it is as approved but there would be one
additional
um unit provided on site whilst we
appreciate the concerns raised by
residents we do consider that
the site can accommodate an additional
parking space details have been
submitted
and reviewed by the local highway
authority and they have raised no
objection
and unlike the previous application um
the local highway authority previously
requested that the existing garages on
site
be conditioned to be remained in use for
parking
as the last application only proposed
one additional unit we didn't think it
was reasonable to
um to add that condition this time
on balance we agreed the local authority
and highway authority and therefore
there is a condition
on this application that does propose to
addition
sorry to retain the existing garages for
parking and i'd also draw your attention
to the additional information report we
have since had
confirmation as with the last
application that the greater manchester
ecology unit are not objecting
um to the application provided we
conditioned that
bed and back boxes be provided within
the new roof
which is a condition on the
recommendation thank you chair
thank you uh believe that
there is one speaker against who's
submitted a statement that's due to be
read out
by ms lowe's i think yesterday
thank you planning objection
39-42 it'll be court this statement is
written to object
to a clear overdevelopment of the
property the current occupancy and
capacity has not been considered
in relation to this planning application
there is already capacity for 20 people
to live in the building
taking account of the bedrooms within
four existing flats
the building cannot fit an additional
two flats and the associated residence
with it
the effect on communal parking and
outdoor spaces for current residents
will be drastic
and our country to our leasehold
agreements the plans have no
consideration of current residence
and the lack of parking on street which
is often full due to being close
being in close proximity to the stretch
of grammar school and cromwell road
which has recently been closed after
traffic resulting in more parking
outside our block from visitors to
longford park
this development of the building does
not reflect the ambitions of the
trafford council's housing strategy
the proposed one-bedroom apartments will
not be suitable for families
will not be affordable housing nor is
there a plan to build sustainably
if the council has failed to provide
enough housing to meet its targets
it is a scandal to then allow them
shoehorning of properties
on top of existing buildings disrupting
established communities
and traffic residents lives
this major works will change the design
and appearance of the building forever
the whole of the roof of the building
will be removed to carry out the
proposed works
the noise disturbance to residents
living in the block will be unbearable
scaffolding and machinery will surround
the building not only blocking light to
residents homes
but also their access to parking and the
garages
how can residents of trafford council
seriously be expected to live and work
in properties
directly below a building site with no
roof
we asked the representative
representatives of trafford council to
put
yourselves in our shoes how would you
feel in our situation
consider the drastic impact this has on
the lives of residents and homeowners
it is saddening that we are in this
situation where we feel that as
residents of trafford council our
concerns and those of our community are
being dismissed and not taken seriously
we feel helpless in a situation where
our lives and homes will be affected
it's important to acknowledge that this
situation has already had a negative
impact on the mental health and anxiety
of the residents
one family are selling their property
and moving out we as a community dread
to think how this huge disturbance to
our personal working lives within our
homes will affect us in the future
the residents of 39 to 42 in goldberg
court
thank you uh ms load um councillor
hartley you've indicated in the chat
yeah did you speak to us
thank you chair um i'd propose that we
we've
in favor of the officer recommendation
um to to grant
i think i think the only the only real
issue for us to to consider i think as
we're outlined in the in the
presentation is is that it's going to be
two additional flats rather
than one and the possible impact that
might have on
on parking the sort of previous
application
which was sort of identical in terms of
the external appearance and the
alterations
but only had one bedroom in the roof
space we we approved that so
so that and it was approved recently set
up permission is still extend
so um you know in effect that's a
fallback position the
the applicant could use so that that
could still happen so i
i sort of think all the considerations
around the external appearance
have been and gone because they've
already been approved as part of that
previous application
um i think when we debated debated it
the first time there was talk about
um the plans and and how there was um
storage space in the roof space and how
that might become
um two apartments and obviously it that
has been
formalized by this application i think
the additional impact of that
of that extra one bedroom apartment is
is not
so significant to to refuse the
application and to say that
you know the site and the property is is
is over developed
um the parking does look does look
tight i mean it looked like there was
room enough to me but um
obviously i know there's the sweat path
analysis as part of the
the application which i think says it
you know it is tight but just about
just about possible only only sort of
query was whether the
the condition to retain the garages was
was actually useful really in some ways
if the garages weren't there it might
afford more space for
for parking um i don't feel strongly
about that i just i just wonder if that
achieves the
the aim of ensuring that adequate
parking space is is sort of maintained
on the site
um so i don't i don't think there's a a
reason a planning reason to refuse this
this application so i'll
i'll happy to propose we vote in in
favor of the officer recommendation
thank you thank you uh council of
councillor punting
thank you chairman as councillor hartley
has very correctly pointed out
essentially ground zero if you will do
it in that way is
is not what's there at the moment the
basic starting point is
the previous application that was
already passed all the
arguments in relation to the amount of
disruption that the residents would face
or
the external look of the appearance of
the building or
it's all now effects that's effectively
been decided already
so what we've got to say is we want to
just if we say no he'll go ahead with
the existing
plans so would we have a major objection
to there being two
flats rather than two flats and storage
and i don't think there's a major
difference between those two positions
we've already seen
that parking is is not going to be the
issue because parking uh contingency
there for it
uh although i would agree with council
hartley also
though uh i'm agreeing with him a great
deal tonight um
i would agree about his comments about
the garages
if we said level them and just put
parking spaces in
formalized parking spaces just paints on
the ground basically
you could probably squeeze more cars in
you could in actual garages
um i don't know whether yeah but there
may be a degree of backfire
in relation to the condition to keep
the garages it may be better for the
residents
generally if if we get rid of that
because it would uh
but it may effectively make the
differences in the intention maybe to
keep the garages anyway so it could
the least heart most time you could do
by taking that away
as far as i can see would be no change
um
if they get to the extent of the moving
places and with painted lines it might
be better just a thought i agree with
council hartley on that also so i'm
going to second the proposal and with
that
say no more
thank you um i haven't clocked any of
the
members as having indicated in the chat
if anybody does want to speak i'll just
give you
um the opportunity to uh indicate there
and but similarly to you councillor
brunson found myself
pretty much entirely in agreement with
council hartley i have to say i think he
sort of said it all really
counsellor jerome you've done
thanksgiving um i'm not going to speak
for long but
i i support what's being said already um
i can't i don't think we've got any
reason to refuse this application
we just wanted to check on the on the
the report and the condition around the
bats
it does say in in the condition that
there'll be tubing
or back bricks um
but yet we've heard that the proposing
previously in the report to put in bat
boxes i just wondered
what the the actual condition is is it
for bat boxes or is it
for for the the tubing into a into the
roof that's being
built within i wasn't quite sure
perhaps we could get a little bit of
clarity on that ms milner
yes the condition i think is tubing i
think this is word is lifted
directly from the comments from our um
colleagues at greater manchester
um ecology unit so it says uh back
bricks or tubes within the development
so
you either all um that that's what
they've said
and how whichever were best incorporated
it does say it's the details to be
submitted to us for approval
so we've not specified a particular one
at this stage and we've not said it's
down to their choice
to do whatever we've said this is what
we need details of
and then that'll come forward and
greater manchester ecology unit will
sign off on that
okay great thanks
[Music]
okay um again no no further members have
indicated that
wishing to speak it has been uh moved
and seconded that we
approved the application in line with
officer recommendation and i suggest
that we move to the vote now um
i've just run through members as you
play on my screen and counselor cut
in favor of officer recommendation
thank you if that may stop you so just
to clarify what we're voting on before
we go ahead and do it
are we voting on the office of
recommendation as
is or are we going to discuss the
possible removal of the condition
in relation to the garage uh and vote on
that
because that was put forward by both
councillor hartley and i
i didn't hear anyone raising the
objection to that point
so can i just clarify on what we're
doing in relation to that condition
first please i've not had a sort of
i haven't clocked a request that um we
have the
garages removed i mean members want to
discuss it further i'm happy
uh and if you want to sort of
i will germany if it helps you in that
okay i'm more than happy to
go along with the recommendation as is i
have no objection to that
um it's just that obviously i and it
doesn't mean that the garages will be
removed it's simply the
condition requesting their attention i'm
just going to remove that
because if they did remove the garages
in the future i don't think that would
do any harm if
anything it could be to the good of the
residents as long as it was
retained for parking uh yeah i
understand what you're saying
um councillor morgan
thank you the only reason i would kind
of possibly
err against what council of huntington
councillor hartley said about the
garages i
similarly have the same view but it's
just law of unintended consequences of
what
i whether taking those garages down and
the impacts that that could have
um i do share the point but if the
applicant wanted to do that
then they could come back at a later
point on that
thank you i don't know councillor
hartley councillor bunting are you happy
with that
yeah i'm happy i mean on balance it's
probably best to keep that
condition in just just thinking it
through um
the concern is obviously to preserve the
adequate parking
provision and i suppose if you have
garages there they can only be used for
well storage or parking your car in if
they were taken away
then you know we'd have to have an
alternative condition really wouldn't
with that
that you know sick you know adequate
parking spaces were maintained on the
site otherwise
they could be knocked down and used for
something else so on balance it's
probably better to keep
the uh keep the condition as is i think
okay so i have no objection to that in
that case we'll go ahead sorry for
interrupting you
no not at all um counselor practice so
i've recorded your vote is in favor
just to be confident that's correct yeah
council
ministers i'll support officer
recommendation to grant thank you
thank you councillor hartley
i'm sorry i missed that then council
sorry chad i don't know if you heard
that you all froze for a minute so it's
probably me
support officer recommendation to grant
thank you wonderful thank you councillor
hunting
the ports officer recommendation thank
you councillor thomas concerned about
the egress and access for parking but
there's no reason for me not to support
our officers of recommendation thank you
councillor stennett
reporting officer's recommendation thank
you councillor stanley uh thank you
support the officer recommendation to
grant thank you councillor holden
bought the officer's recommendation
thank you councillor morgan
support officer recommendations to grant
chair thank you
councillor i also support some
recommendation to grant thanks joe
thank you and councillor dr barclay
a support officer recommendation to
grant thank you chairman
thank you and i will also be voting in
line with officer recommendation to
grant
so that application is approved and the
last application for consideration
tonight is
uh that i've landed north of oprah park
which is on page 38
the committee report and this item will
be introduced by
mrs lewis
i will just share my screen
okay because is that clear to everybody
yeah great thank you and this
application relates to a site at the
junction of oak road and wilberton lane
in partington
march 2020 the planning and development
committee granted permission for the
erection of 75 affordable houses
on the site a condition of this
permission condition 11
required the demolition of 75
residential units with
existing units within your housing group
stock in partington before any
occupation of the proposed developments
could take place
in order to mitigate harm to the highway
network and result in a neutral
impact this application before us
tonight
seeks to remove condition 11 and allow
more flexible means of dealing with the
higher impacts
through the use of a section 106 legal
agreement to allow for contributions
towards the carrington relief road
this is all we are considering within
this application and the development
otherwise remains
unchanged as a result this application
seeks to provide
greater certainty that the new 75
affordable properties could be occupied
once completed
by replacing condition 11 with a section
106 agreement that would allow for the
option of either
a financial contribution towards the
current relief road in line with the crr
strategy
demolition of existing residential units
in your housing group stock in
partington
or the more likely scenario a
combination of both
it is considered to appropriately
mitigate the highway impacts
identified of the development this
contribution towards the carrington
relief road is over and above what was
expected through the crr strategy
and brings the additional benefits of
helping to fund the road and making it
more deliverable
the local highways authority have raised
no objections to the proposal
and have stated a preference for the
current leapfrog contribution
in order to address the identified harm
from the development to the local
highway network
the application is therefore recommended
approve for approval
subject to all the same conditions are
conditional 11
and a section 106 legal agreement
thank you
thank you ms lowe's um believe that
there's one speaker against it
ms williams who submitted a written
statement things to be read out
i'll be reading that out chairman okay
thank you
houses will include removing healthy
50-year-old trees
they are the habitat of local wildlife
and planting new trees would be no help
to them
they can hardly be given a relocation
notice
the air quality in trafford is very poor
and we have already seen hundreds of
trees destroyed by house builders in the
past year
the only main road in partington is
gridlock daily during rush hour as it is
there's hundreds more houses planned
over the next decade and no real plan
for improvement
yesterday's been a few ideas but the
best of them just sent the traffic buyer
a different route which then rejoins the
same road further down
these so-called affordable homes are out
of the price range of many people in the
area
the people who can afford to buy also
need to be able to get to and from work
impossible on these roads with
congestion in every direction
you're putting in bike sheds to
encourage people to cycle to work
i used to cycle to work in college years
ago and trust me our country lanes
involve taking your life in your hands
in rush
hour besides how our family went to a
weekly or monthly shop for a family on a
bicycle
we have the tiniest tesco ever as our
largest supermarket so people have to
shop outside the area
there will be insufficient doctors and
other health services to accommodate all
those new residents
then there's the problem where their
children will go to school
we have three primary schools in an area
which used to have six
they don't have the capacity for
hundreds of extra children
building a decent sized supermarket like
aldi or lidl would make more sense and
may even make the area more appealing
the oak road area there's just one small
independent grocery off license shop
again insufficient many people don't
have cars and to get on a bus with young
children to shop outside the area
is very difficult if not even possible
the elderly also struggle with shopping
i beg you beg you to reconsider your
ideas for allowing this application to
go through
and for once think of the people who
live here you have already built on
every available green space we have
don't give us any more your housing
should be spending on repairs for their
existing properties
and take care of their tenants thank you
for listening thank you chairman
thank you um there any members looking
to open
the discussion to this item
counselor jerome extra
i i do feel um sympathy for the
residents that have objected
um they do point out that they would
like to see developer contributions
going to things like
um ecology mitigation um for
infrastructure to schools uh to local
shops
but yet we're seeing um more developer
contribution go to the
carrington relief rate um which i don't
think is a relief road at all i think it
would bring extra traffic into the area
possibly more pollution um so yeah i've
got great sympathy with the residents
here
um that more developer contributions
aren't going to some of those things
that
they've mentioned and yeah i i feel
strongly about
so i'll put up i'll be listening to what
others have to say also
thanks joe thank you and councillor
thomas
thanks chair in in line with uh
councillor jerome
i don't believe that the relief road as
it is planned
will give any relief to partington
itself per se because
it'd still be the bottleneck through
part in the village
having said that the need for affordable
housing
is a great concern of mine and
whilst it would pain me to to to
hold up on that um i think i have to
support this motion
or support the the officer's decision
with a heavy heart
so we do need to bear in mind as a
planning committee as a council in the
whole
the impact of where the relief road
runs and how people pass through
parkinson
as a whole including around this uh
application
thanks joe thank you and i suppose what
i'd say
sort of uh reflecting on those remarks
is that
what's before us this evening isn't an
application about the relief or about
where ideally we'd like and developer
contributions to
to be spent it's it's a bit of an
unusual uh application this and that
it's a lengthy report which is actually
just about
amending the condition and relating to
developer contribution and
as as i understand it we're actually
likely to
receive a greater contribution and from
this developer as a consequence of
amending this condition
so um with that in mind my own view is
that
really we should be we should be
accepting this and trying to think about
it in the
in the best possible interpretation that
can
um now i can't see any of the members
having
indicated counselor bunsen has now
indicated and council holds enough clock
that you just put your hand up as well
cancel the punting thank you chairman
um again yes i accept that they're
trying to basically change their
condition and that's what we're talking
about
they're basically giving us some money
towards the relief road that isn't a
relief road in order to try and avoid
the obligations which they've already
entered into with us
in other words we made a deal with them
and now they want to
sort of break the deal in exchange for
handing us a few quid
towards the relief road which is
essentially what we're talking about
doing this
i i accept a lot of residents um
concerns about you know yes and but that
they're not
necessarily directly relevant in terms
of where the supermarket should go
that's not the argument we're making and
this is yeah there's three
trees but they're not tpo then what have
you so except so that
i'm not going on the residence those
arguments of residents raised in our
objection
i just feel that we the condition was
put in for a good reason
i don't feel that the additional money
to the
uh to the to the relief that isn't
will mitigate the problems that this
will cause in the way the condition will
mitigate the problems
that this will cause and therefore i
would ask that the
uh developer the the housing association
your housing group
do that which they said they were going
to do when this application came in
originally honor the commitment they
have already made
and stick by their word uh on those
grounds chairman
i would uh suggest that we should uh
reject officer recommendation we'll
refuse and
ask that they stick to that which have
already said they were going
to do thank you
councillor holden thank you chair
i feel very uncomfortable about this
situation
we have apparently
or an acknowledged shortage of housing
in trafford yet here we have a
council process which is sanctioning the
destruction
of 75 existing houses to replace them
with
around about the same
this confuses me i know i'm a little old
man and i get confused
easily but what how on earth can we
justify
destroying 75 homes to replace them with
the same number of homes
when everywhere else in the borough
we're trying to expand the numbers
thank you council i mean i i see you're
indicating council of the mogan i
suppose in response to that and that i'd
say this is the booklet saint martin's
or
counselor and i've spent a lot of time
on that estate and
really i think that the the grounds for
your housing group wanting to demolish
the properties around you that road is
essentially
because they're pursuing a state
regeneration the properties
are very typical of that era of
manchester city council over still
estates and
if we're honest about it they weren't
built to a particularly good standard
and they had they have really quite
serious problems with
damp um and as a consequence i think
your housing group have essentially
uh made a determination that um it's
beyond the scope of improving them
through repairs and actually the state
needs to be regenerated with new builds
and now councilman morgan you've
indicated
um thank you chair um and i do kind of
take on board particularly what you've
said as a local award counsellor
um i was probably i have to be honest
i'm quite surprised um
in terms of how the debate's gone um i
was pretty minded to
very in favor of this i do take on board
what you've said in terms of
the housing stock but if this is the
view of your housing group then
i don't really see the the reason to
retain this
um condition on that that is
if if that's their intention then they
will go about that
anyway or should go about that um i
really do feel
kind of like uncomfortable as
encouraging the demolition of housing
stock when
we um we have a massive shortage of
housing stock right across the board
on all housing 10 years in all all
housing sizes
um so i mean i will continue to listen
to the debate
um but i am minded to to vote very often
recommendations certainly
um in line with the developer
contributions
but thank you
thank you council hartley thank you
yeah i would also um want to vote in
in favor of the recommendation to grant
subjected agreement
being uh being concluded i think as you
said chair that
if if the if the applicant contributes
if all of the contributions towards the
carrington relief
we will probably get a higher value
contribution
and i think i think the context for this
is
is the is the is the planning uh the
paper that we approved
um at our meeting back in october i
think which is that
um developments in the this is a
paragraph 21 of the report as well so
it summarizes that paper effectively and
says development in the carrington
strategic location and wider partington
will make a contribution to the
carrington relief road um
so that's the situation that that we've
got now so um
if an application for we've had
applications for for
a lot more housing than this in the
partington area and seeking that
contribution towards the carrington
relief road is
is now standard because that's the
approach that we've approved
so as i understand it essentially this
application is is
saying well can the applicant pursue
that option instead
um you know the original proposal was
that um
housing was demolished and i agree that
that seems that seems perverse
um so the application essentially is
seeking to remove that condition
and allow the applicant to make the
contribution towards the relief road
as as any other developer would who was
make bringing forward an application
in in that area so i i i don't really
have much hesitation in saying that we
should approve the officer
recommendation to
to grant this one thank you
thank you councillor um i can't see
any of the members having indicated that
they'd like to speak i mean
i've heard what i've got to say and i
should say that i'm happy to propose
that we um support officer
recommendation to grant
formally um i think there's been a
proposal
to the contrary by council bunting am i
right now
okay
and then so we've had a proposal for a
proposal against
but i don't think either motion's been
seconded i'm i'm happy to second you
check thank you council
um so we've now had
it moved that we when we've done the
second did that we support officer
recommendation
uh and it proposed but not seconded uh
to the contrary i'll just skip members
if they did want to speak
the opportunity to indicate in the chat
because i'm conscious that
that's a little bit confusing
[Music]
no okay well in that case we'll move to
the vote then and
that would be uh to support officer
recommendation
um and i'll just run through members as
they appear on the screen
counselor proctor i support the officer
rendation
thank you council the minis
um i'm not a great fan of the road but
uh
i shall i can't see any reason to say no
i'm afraid to that what's what's been
put before us with the
uh about the demolition of the 75 so um
i'll be voting
to support uh officer recommendation to
grant
thank you thank you
thank you support the officer
recommendation to grant thank you
thank you uh councillor bunting
officer recommendation for the reasons i
outlined earlier
i either i don't believe the uh the
payment in relation to the leaflet we'll
achieve the same end as
the condition 11 which we are removing
thank you gentlemen
thank you um councillor thomas
support the officer recommendation chair
thank you
uh councillor support officer's
recommendation to grant
thank you and councilwoman stanley
uh thank you chair extremely pleased to
support the officer recommendation
thank you councillor councillor holden
support
the officer's recommendation thank you
uh councillor johann council minister
i'm reluctantly uh supporting officer
recommendation on this condition
thank you and councillor morgan uh sport
officer recommendation to grants
jeff thank you and
councillor dr berkley i support office
of recommendation to grant thank you
chairman
and i shall also be casting a vote in
support of officer recommendation to
grant um
so that motion is carried uh
we're now turned to the outstanding
items on the agenda um item eight
relates to uh the revision of the
application validation checklist
uh a report that was circulated and
that's going to be introduced by mr day
yeah um thank you chair um
i think yeah ms coley is just uploading
the
slideshow um so yeah this report is to
inform committee of the latest revision
to the application validation checklist
and the key proposed changes to the
document and to seek approval of the
draft checklist for consultation
purposes
paragraph 39 of the national planning
practice guidance making an application
states that our local planning authority
may request supporting information with
a planning application
its requirements should be specified on
a formally adopted local list
which has been published on its website
less than two years before the
application is submitted
so there's a need to review the
validation checklist every two years
this is the third review of the
checklist since it was first
introduced and the current document
dates from 2018.
um and the mppg states that when where
changes are proposed
consultation should take place with a
local community including
applicants and agents so a draft updated
validation checklist 2021
has been produced and has appended to
the report
the structure of the document has not
been altered in terms of key changes a
number of new requirements have been
introduced
as well as minor alterations to existing
sections of the checklist
the new requirements are listed on the
screen and include for example
an accommodation schedule setting out
the
size of residential units with reference
to the nationally described space
standards
and accurate visual representations a
form of computer visual
visualization uh required when a
development is likely to have a
significant effect
on heritage assets or the surrounding
landscape
and the others listed on the screen
there
minor alterations are also proposed to
other sections of the checklist
as listed on the on the next slide
these include flood risk and drainage in
respect to which further proposed
changes are set out in judicial
information reports
so the proposed changes to the checklist
are intended to ensure that the
validation requirements
are in accordance with local and
national policies and up-to-date advice
from consultees
and are reasonable and necessary to
allow the proper assessment of planning
applications
it's therefore recommended that the
committee note the contents of the
report
and approve the application validation
checklist for consultation purposes
and that the header planning be
authorized to
adopt the revised validation checklist
in the event that following consultation
there were no significant alterations to
the consultation
draft thank you chair
thank you mr day um just to clarify the
members this is something that
we're gonna have to vote on um
if members have any questions or wish to
discuss
and uh perhaps indicate in the chat or i
should say i'm i'm
more than happy to move the um we do as
advised by mr day uh note the um report
and uh uh the changes to the
application validation checklist for
consultation
and is there anybody machine to comment
oh councillor bunting i can see that
you've seconded that
and anybody wishing to comment before we
move to about
no okay um counsellor proctor
to approve the report thank you thank
you council
minis to approve thank you
thank you councillor hartley thank you
chair i
have to approve the um the report thank
you council of hunting
recommendations thank you
councillor thomas thank you chair fully
approved
thank you councillor stannet approved
cheer thank you councillor win stanley
thank you chair happy to approve thank
you councillor holden approve
thank you councillor direct thanks jen
thank you councilman morgan approved
please check
thank you and councillor dr berkley
you thank you i shall also uh
be voting uh
as other members that is noted
and approved um gender item number nine
relates to
188a through shrewsbury street in an
article for
direction and i think ms milner is just
going to
um introduce that
thank you chair i'll just uh quickly
share my screen with you
so we are proposing um
an article called article 4 direction to
remove the committed development rights
for
demolition of 188 a shruti street in old
trafford
this is a site location plan of the
building and here are some photographs
of the building as it starts currently
it's the red brick
structure that extends along shroopy
street
i'm not seeing different slides for me
to check
um you're not seeing the
you can only see your initial title page
and a part of the map
below it i can't we can't see the whole
it's not scrolling or moving or anything
it's just got your title
right i'll try i'll i'll stop sharing
and i'll share it again because it is
moving on
on mine i think i think ms milner i
think it's
you're sharing your screen you're not
sharing the i think you need to start
the presentation
effectively in powerpoint and then share
your screen i think it's not it's not a
powerpoint
it's a it's the way i we i think it's
going to be the connection
hello i'll share it because i've got the
right reader for that
and just move through it just bear with
me when i get okay
it's a it's the pdf one f saved
that should be working now
you see remember seeing a photograph
there
yeah i'm seeing nods excellent
all right uh i'll get back to my
since an article four directions enables
the local planning authority to remove
committed development rights for certain
developments
trafford already has a borough wide
article for removing committed
development rights for
hmos and a number of conservation areas
and also have householder permitted
developments removed through article
four directions
the proposed article for direction would
remove permitted development rights for
the demolition of one eight a structure
street old trafford
this is considered necessary as the
demolition would be prejudicial to the
proper planning of the area
and constitutes a threat to the
amenities of the area
an immediate article for direction is
required as the property could be
demolished
between a non-immediate article four
being made and coming into force
and one a shrewsbury street is not
protected by any statutory heritage
designated
it is not a listed building or in a
conservation area but it is considered
to be a non-designated heritage asset
its demolition would be harmful to the
visual amenities of the area
whilst in need of some repair it is
attractive in its own right and has
historic
significance to the area demolition
would lead to the total loss of its
heritage significance compensation may
be payable if future planning
applications
planning applications demolitions are
refused it would be
not be payable on the making or
confirming of the article 4 direction
it is therefore proposed that any future
planning application
which may generate a subsequent
compensation claim be referred to
in the committee reports for
determination
and committee can give weight to that in
the planning balance
no consultation has been carried out at
this stage and
consultation and notification to those
with an interest in the land including
the owner
and surrounding residents and any other
interesting parties will be made
once the direction is confirmed approval
is sought for members to make the
direction and therefore
move on to the the part next part of the
process
it is noticed that there was a previous
um application for the demolition
of the building under permitted
development rights late last year which
was refused um due to a technicality
and therefore we do consider that the
there is an immediate um risk to the the
loss of the building and therefore
look to support for the article for
direction
and any questions on the legal process
will be answered by the legal team
thank you thank you
uh ms milner just to confirm for members
it's similar to the previous item in
that we will have to vote
on whether or not to approve the article
for direction um
if there is any member looking to speak
please indicate in the chat i would just
say i'm happy to propose that we accept
the article for direction and i should
just let members know as well that and
in january i was contacted by the
consulate general of poland in
manchester who explained and i wasn't
aware of this that
and this building apparently has um
particular significance for the polish
diaspora community in manchester
um as it used to be a polish club i
understand um
so i think that is interesting out there
i wasn't aware of this particular site
and so i'm very happy to support
the article for direction um
counselor bunting i think you've
indicated that
thank you chairman um simply very little
to say on this but
um some say i agree with the officers on
this one entirely
and i'm more than happy to second your
proposal
i think this is a valuable asset to the
area
and to see it level
the reason would be uh would be very
unfortunate so
more than happy to
i think the connection got a bit
interrupted by cancer but i think
i think we got the gist of what you were
saying and councillor halloween
thank you chair yeah i'm happy to to
second your your recommendation that we
that we approve the the making of this
direction it's
it's not a building guy i i knew about
but having been and had a look at it i i
can well see the
the value of it as a non-heritage asset
and uh
you know i think the report is it's
really interesting uh i thought anyway
and
and i think it it outlines the the sort
of importance of the asset in terms of
its social history both in terms of
you know it's its original uses as a
unitarian church and
and then as you say the subsequent use
of part of the building as the polish
uh ex-servicemen's club and that speaks
a lot to
you know the polish diaspora in
manchester that that social history and
it's of architectural
uh merit as well but you know the
architects have designed other prominent
manchester buildings
so yeah i mean it's in a state of
disrepair and uh
and and finding a use for a building of
that sort would be will be difficult i
think
but happy to approve the making of this
direction so that at least of a
proposal is made to to demolish the
building it comes to the committee for
for full consideration
thank you chair thank you councillor
councilman morgan
i thank you chair really really briefly
and i i will be supporting the motion
and agree with everything everyone said
i think uh but council carl has just
taken my thunder on this it's not just a
pirate club it's actually
um it's a polish check servicemen's club
um and i think this is really really
important in terms of some of the
um the polish community who came over
here um basically 80 years ago many of
whom never went
were able to go home i think it's really
really important and we recognise that
um that part of the history thank you
thank you councillor um has now been
proposed and seconded that we accept the
article for direction
and i'll just run through members
casting their vote as you pay on my
school
counselor proctor yeah happy to approve
the article for direction thank you chad
thank you council minis i'm happy to
approve the
um ask for direction to protect our
non-designated
heritage asset thank you thank you
councillor harvey
i could sure have to approve the making
of the direction thank you
thank you bunting happy to approve
chairman
you counselor thomas
you sure happy to approve thank you
counselors done it
happy to approve chair it's a long time
coming
thank you um councillor winston
uh happy to approve the money of the
direction share thank you
thank you councillor holden i was happy
to approve
with the arrival of the white eagle of
pole
[Music]
thank you councillor morgan
happy to approve chair thank you and
councillor dr barclay
i approve thank you chairman thank you i
shall also
uh be voting to improve the article for
direction and
that motions carried unanimously um
i haven't been notified of any urgent
business um unless anybody wishes to
raise anything now suggest that we close
the meet